well the war in Ukraine has pushed
Russia to seek closer ties with China
and other International partners and
that's playing out right now in Cape
Town where foreign ministers from the
bricks creeping of emerging economies
are meeting Brazil Russia India China
and hosts South Africa are discussing
the possible expansion of the Block it's
increasingly seen as an alternative to
Western geopolitical dominance so just
how far though could the blocks
expansion go around 20 countries have
voiced their interest in joining they
include Saudi Arabia Iran Nigeria
Indonesia to kie and Mexico for Russia
it could be a chance to widen its circle
of friends as it faces sanctions because
of the war in Ukraine it could also be
an opportunity for China which proposed
the expansion at last year's Summit it
wants to portray itself as a
counterbalance to the West brics members
are also looking at reducing Reliance on
the US dollar as a reserve currency
especially in trade a policy known as
the dollarization well let's speak to
femita Miller she's across this for us
in Cape Town for me to I understand that
friends of bricks will actually be
addressing the meeting today just How
likely is this Prospect of expansion
well given what the South African
minister of international relations and
cooperation said yesterday uh said
earlier just a few hours ago with regard
to the expansion it is key to the
meeting today and they are looking at at
least 19 countries expressing interest
whether formally or informally now the
minister had said that the members of
brics and those interested in joining do
represent a majority of the global
population and so this I think would be
very important in terms of Greater
representation for what the what brics
considers very important the global
South but to give us a better idea of
what that expansion might look like and
what it might involve we're speaking to
International Affairs journalists Peter
fabricius now Peter the
expansion is is very important to Bricks
at this point especially in terms of
creating this alternative
um oppose you know the G20 or G7 but
what is the criteria that they might be
looking at when bringing in new members
I think it is quite problematic in a way
actually because I mean one of the main
criteria is actually that no one no
country that's admitted should have a a
really intractable issue with the brics
member so I would imagine for example
that Pakistan is not going to be joining
bricks in any great Harry because India
has a real issue and there may be some
similar issues with China and some of
the the the countries that it has
disputes within the South China Sea on
the same score and I would also you know
the other thing about bricks is that
it's it's a kind of a slightly and
building sort of organization because I
think it likes to see itself as
non-aligned but you know if in in the
increasing polarized world that we earn
at the moment where Russia and the and
the West NATO are at each other's
throats you know to have one of those
pulls of the new conflict that is
already a brics member creates a
complication there so I would say any
country that has a kind of Western
leaning I mean we're not going to get
Australia joining we're not going to get
New Zealand Joy you know any country
that has a a western kind of orientation
is is unlikely to join so I mean it's so
we're beyond that it's hard to say you
can't say it's about democracy and human
rights human rights maybe they could
pass off but democracy maybe not
considering China and Russia or China
particularly
so it's going to be a bit difficult
actually to and that's why they didn't
agree you know yesterday I mean the the
foreign ministers didn't agree on on the
expansion and they kicked that ball down
the road to The Summit in August
and aside from seeking common values and
the difficulties they have to navigate
in terms of membership they do want to
increase trade there really is an
economic focus and they're looking at
potentially a common currency How likely
is that amongst these diverse countries
well I don't I think that the the common
currency of brics country is very far
down the road you know uh Neil sukla the
South African Serpa actually said that
yesterday and he's told me that before
that it's it's that would be very
ambitious but in the meanwhile what
they're doing is is trying to increase
trade in each other's currencies so and
and the idea is clearly to try and
reduce the dependence on the dollar
which also means that naledi Pando the
South African foreign minister said is
to to increase their vulnerability to
U.S sanctions because those sanctions
are very much about trading and dollar
so if you can trade in your own
currencies fact and then somewhere down
the line maybe you know that could
evolve into a brics currency hi Peter
thank you very much for your time
speaking there to Peter fabricia is an
international affairs analyst these
meetings will continue for the next
couple of hours but likely we'll wrap
from amongst these foreign ministers
today
with all the latest for us from Cape
Town thank you femita